this one
might surprise you
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and i will be finally
discussing something i get asked about
constantly here on my channel
my top tips for healthy weight gain but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
squarespace now if you're not familiar
with squarespace it's an all-in-one
platform to run your business whether
you're looking to build a website blog
online store or use their marketing
tools and analytics i am admittedly not
very tech savvy so i often find it very
overwhelming to coordinate all the
different moving parts on my blog using
a service like squarespace to easily
manage your seo email list and calendar
not to mention easily import information
from twitter and instagram is a huge
time saver and also very convenient it's
just so nice not to stress over the
little things and to instead focus on
what really matters so you can check out
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain all
right and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a big reminder that
this is not a substitute for unique
one-on-one medical and nutrition advice
i strongly suggest that you speak to a
registered dietitian or doctor about
your unique weight gain needs and of
course do not forget to subscribe to
this channel and ring that little bell
so that you never miss out on a episode
okay so before we dive too deep into my
tips here i want to acknowledge that
there are a number of reasons why many
people may be looking to purposefully
gain weight i know the common narrative
in our society is all about weight loss
but there's actually a lot of you who
ask me specifically about how to gain
weight or to eat more calories when
maybe your hunger doesn't drive you to
do that naturally so for some people
this could be generally to just support
better health since we know that under
eating and being underweight is
associated with malnutrition
vitamin deficiencies osteoporosis
decreased immune function fertility
issues growth and development problems
and digestive issues and that's just to
name a few now folks in eating disorder
recovery specifically may be trying to
weight restore and improve their
nutrition status but might be struggling
with blunted hunger cues so if you've
been severely restricting and now trying
to eat more to gain weight i strongly
advise speaking to a registered
dietitian who specializes in weight gain
or disordered eating before beginning
this journey in some cases of any sort
of recovery eating more could actually
be dangerous to your health but of
course once you get some guidance and
clearance from your doctor hopefully
these tips can be beneficial to you as
well now others might be looking to gain
weight for performance reasons related
to sport or fitness goals or just their
daily activities of life and then
there's also a lot of you who message me
about low appetite strategies in general
so whether that be related to
medications like ssris or stimulants for
like adhd or to health conditions like
digestive disorders anxiety and
depression whatever the reason i do
understand why people may feel that they
need expert advice for gaining weight
and that they may want to do it in a way
that supports their health long term
not just by adding calories in the form
of lots of pastries and fries and soda i
mean those foods can absolutely be part
of the plan
but we still want to make sure that
we're feeling our best in this process
too and that generally means eating
foods that support our energy needs
cognitive capacity and also good
digestion so with that in mind here are
my top tips i'm going to start with the
more practical tips and then move on to
the more higher level suggestions tip
number one focus on calorie dense foods
so this might seem like a bit of a
no-brainer since foods that are super
high volume but low in calories can take
up a lot of precious real estate in our
tummy and make it really hard for us to
get the nutrition that we really need so
you want to focus most eating
opportunities on really calorie dense
foods that are lower in water and fiber
content and higher in healthy fats or
protein so think about things like full
fat dairy avocado nuts and seeds salad
dressing added oils dried fruit and
smoothies over lots of big salads or
broth-based soups enjoying salad is
totally fine we still need our
vegetables and fruit but we want to make
sure that that salad is packed with lots
of nuts dressing starchy veggies and
whole grains and not just ahead of
romaine now tip number two eat smaller
meals more frequently eating smaller and
more frequent meals not only provides
more opportunities to get calories in
but it's also slightly easier on your
digestion and can also be
psychologically less overwhelming if
you're used to eating just like a fist
full of food seeing a plate piled really
high is going to probably turn you off
and freak you out so aim to eat a
portion that you can tolerate every two
to four hours each day or aim for about
three meals and two to three snacks per
day tip three hydrate with extra
calories research suggests that it's a
lot easier to drink calories than to eat
them which is why in my weight loss
video i suggested trying to limit high
calorie drinks but if you're actively
trying to gain weight adding calories to
your beverages is actually a lot easier
physically and psychologically than
chewing all of that food
so for example a cup of orange juice
generally is equivalent to approximately
three whole oranges but it's a lot
faster and easier to drink that cup of
juice than to peel and slice and chew
all that fruit so while i'm not
suggesting that you shouldn't have any
straight up water in your day you can
also meet a lot of your hydration needs
with extra calories by adding in things
like juice smoothies with protein powder
nut butter and full fat yogurt
milk or kefir and making sure that those
things get into the daily rotation now
tip number four
hydrate after you eat so we discussed
how choosing calorie filled beverages is
a great bang for your stomach space buck
but when you do want to just have
straight up h2o i recommend spacing your
water consumption out from your meals so
drinking a ton of water before a meal
can stretch the stomach temporarily and
make it more uncomfortable for you to
fill it with a nutrient-dense meal so of
course hydrate when you're thirsty but
unless it's got calories try to consume
the bulk of your fluids after you've
gotten your food fill now tip number
five
use calorie filled liquids in place of
water in all your recipes so still on
the topic of fluid and water you can
swap in whole milk cream canned coconut
milk evaporated milk or juice in place
of water in a wide range of recipes so
whether you're making cereal oatmeal
coffee soups sauces or spreads adding a
calorie calorie-filled liquid in can add
a ton of flavor a nice rich body and
extra calories without any additional
bulk or the perception of having more
food in your day moving on to tip six
dip it up
you know the song you know when i dip
you dip we dip
[Music]
make that your new mealtime anthem aka
makes sauces dips and dressings your bff
because let's be honest right like
everything tastes better with a nice
sauce so now is definitely not the time
to skip so i say add some hummus with
your crackers
make some chocolate into some greek
yogurt for dipping with fruit and
drizzle tahini over grilled veggies and
meats one of my favorites from my
cookbook the mindful glow cookbook is my
thai peanut hummus which is loaded with
protein and healthy fats so i'm gonna
leave a link to that below also when
you're in a pinch olive oil and butter
also does the trick oils and fats are a
really easy way to add flavor calories
and some extra nutrition without adding
bulk or volume to your meal so they can
really help to cut down on the work of
eating to gain tip number seven add
sprinkles to everything so take a tip
out of my toddler parenting tip book
sprinkles make everything way more fun
and yes this totally could be standard
rainbow sprinkles that we're talking
about but it could also be really any
nutritious yummies like crumbled cheese
or nuts or seeds all of my dedicated ak
followers will know that i sprinkle hemp
hearts onto literally
everything that i eat smoothies soups
salads avocado toast you name it i love
it since one tablespoon of hemp hearts
contains 50 calories with 5 grams of
healthy fats and over three grams of
protein they also add a really yummy
nutty flavor so
yeah trust me sprinkles are life all
right moving on to some more general
higher level tips tip number eight is to
focus on making food fun when i talk to
people who are actively trying to
rekindle their hunger cues in an effort
to gain weight one of the biggest
complaints that i hear is that it often
can feel like a chore ironically boredom
is also one of the biggest complaints
that people have on weight loss diets as
well and to me that does make a lot of
sense
[Music]
seeing as there really is only so much
that you can do when you're limiting
sauces and types of foods and other
flavor enhancers when you're trying to
cut calories anywhere that you can but
the sky is literally the limit when true
abundance is the goal so make mealtimes
fun exciting and special by busting out
a new cookbook and experimenting in the
kitchen and heading full force into
flavor town when each meal is something
that you're genuinely looking forward to
eating because like it's new and novel
and fun you're less likely to be tempted
to skip it or to forget to eat and that
brings me to tip number nine be prepared
interestingly again i had the same tip
in my weight loss video which i think
really goes to show that in our super
busy society healthy eating does
sometimes require some intentional
action on your part this is particularly
true when you're trying to eat despite
maybe not having the biological drive to
eat so food has really got to be easy as
[ __ ] i recommend always having a few
pre-prepared meals or meal components or
snacks on hand at the ready that you can
just easily pop in the microwave or
throw in your work bag to eliminate that
extra hurdle to getting your meal or
snack in so anytime you're cooking a
recipe just double or triple it and then
freeze some for another night or if
you're grilling up some extra protein
make extra and then keep them in the
fridge for some easy meals as for snacks
they don't have to be all homemade
please don't make this any more
stressful for yourself i think there's a
ton of fantastic store-bought options
that can definitely help you meet your
needs between meals and help to
supplement meals and this brings me to
tip number 10
develop and stick to a meal routine this
is particularly important for folks in
eating disorder recovery or those who
don't have clear hunger cues because you
basically need to train your body to
expect and need food so we call this
mechanical feeding but by feeding your
body regularly and routinely you start
to actually feel hunger at those
specific times as your metabolism starts
to basically kick back into gear so for
some people the easiest thing to do is
to actually set alarms or like
reoccurring meetings in your calendar
basically you're making a commitment to
yourself and to your body to take care
of yourself at those times i know this
feels super unnatural and also maybe
some of you may feel a little bit
selfish or guilty devoting so much time
in the day to yourself especially when
you aren't even responding to a really
strong biological need but i promise you
with some time your body will respond
with a really good reinforcing cue and
speaking of reinforcement tip number 11
is to get social i know this isn't
always possible and covet has definitely
made this a challenge for a lot of folks
but try to eat in the company of others
whenever you can loneliness and
depression are huge sources of low
appetite and they can also reinforce
restrictive behaviors but eating with
others not only makes experience more
novel and fun which we already talked
about being really important but
research also suggests that people do
tend to eat more in the presence of
others so invite family over for dinner
pick up smoothies with a friend on a
walk do a zoom cake and coffee catch up
with a friend or make a point to join a
co-worker for lunch hour and if your
friends aren't available you can also
always volunteer at like a local
retirement home soup kitchen or
mentorship program with some kids if
this pandemic has taught us anything
it's that the benefits of human
connection are truly boundless did we
just become best friends yep now my last
two tips are for those who are
struggling with low appetite so tip
number 12 is to focus on cold or
odorless items this is particularly
helpful for folks who are dealing with
nausea maybe related to pregnancy or
medication or just emotional exhaustion
trying to eat beyond one's cues but if
you're having just a really rough eating
day you may find it's best to avoid
anything really hot or too aromatic most
people find that a smoothie or maybe a
smoothie frozen into a homemade popsicle
might be easier to stomach than let's
say a fragrant aromatic stir fry or a
pot of chili on those days when really
nothing sounds appealing now everyone is
going to figure out what is best
tolerated for them and of course
depending on one's culture and their own
personal comfort foods something hot and
fragrant might just do the trick but
generally speaking folks struggling with
nausea report neutral foods typically do
go down best and finally that brings me
to my final tip
make a safe meal list i don't mean safe
foods that are diet friendly and low in
calories as many of you may have done in
the past during your restrictive eating
days i mean foods that you feel that you
can tolerate when you're struggling with
low appetite
nausea or lack of motivation and time
and really nothing sounds great for you
to eat this is for those days when
you've asked yourself what do i feel
like today and
ultimately
nothing comes to mind so you need a list
of easy to access foods that you at
least feel neutral about you don't be
jazzed about them but they're familiar
and accessible enough that if you're
having a day where you just can't with
another meal or snack that you know that
they're going to be there for you
[Music]
so these may be more bland or simple
comfort foods like peanut butter toast
or crackers and cheese or they could be
something totally unique to your culture
and childhood not every meal or snack
needs to be revolutionary sometimes they
just need to nourish you in that moment
to help get you by so i do hope that was
helpful for those who asked about
healthy weight gain but i want to
emphasize that i strongly recommend
working with a registered dietitian or
another medical professional if you
yourself are in a situation that
requires weight restoration like i said
earlier in a lot of cases it may
actually be dangerous to just jump all
in if you're starting from a place of
severe restriction so always speak to a
doctor and dietitian about your unique
case now if you've been on a weight gain
journey yourself and have discovered a
really great tip or trick that's really
helped you i would love if you would
share it with the rest of us in the
comment section below and that is it for
today's video folks thank you again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
what you'd like to see me discuss next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye